[Music]
that documentary was so magnificent I
think I started crying like 2 and a half
minutes in and then Justin kept coming
and kept coming but there was a lot of I
just think what's great about the
documentary if I can interject very
quickly is you see the enormous amount
of talent behind the scenes thousands of
people that work on the film there's a
reason the end credits here an hour and
a half long and that's what I remember
so much is the that that the crew was
just so on top of their game and
everyone's so happy to be making a Star
Wars movie it's impossible not to have
fun Ryan talked about a lot of the input
that the actors had and one of them
being that it was your decision to
actually kiss Carrie on the forehead
during the Luke and Leia moment but I
didn't decide it and say can I do this I
mean in the take even I definitely
rehearsed it or not but it just happened
and I was standing up and they weren't
ready for and they said no do that again
and we did it for a second take it like
I say it was just spontaneous and a
really momentous for me because Luke was
saying goodbye to his sister forever and
of course you know to finally just to
have to lose Carrie was just it's just I
can't watch that scene it's just you
know takes me out of the movie
completely I'll get over it but you know
she'll be forever missed and she's
irreplaceable yeah it was a very
emotional emotional scene to watch
no one's ever really gone there were a
few others as well that that really got
me watching you with Frank Oz and Yoda
well that character means so much to me
I mean I remember reading Empire for the
first time I'm thinking wow I mean he's
so deep and spiritual and cerebral as
all these course Luke never realized and
he he's right in front of it I didn't
recognize obi-wan when he was right
there you know I didn't realize you know
I'm irritated but like he's some gremlin
or fraud going through my food I'm
looking for a great Jedi warrior you
know so it meant a lot to me not only to
have that chance to revisit that
character but to do it old-school
instead of doing CGI
having Frank there the puppet made from
the original molds in the documentary
see I didn't really you know I'm going
to rehearse with Frank I didn't know
they were gonna have you know the
partial set I mean I just didn't expect
that to be moving to me I thought oh boy
it's Frank and Frank that's always fun
but you know the whole experience
whether it's visiting the Moline Falken
for the first time or seeing you note
again it's it's so unexpected you know I
mean they say you can never go home
again and all of a sudden there you are
it's indescribable that's another thing
going on the monument list oh great I
brought the family it's gonna be fun now
you can see the set and of the Han Solo
ship and the detail the every oil drip
every dent the hanging tubes it even
smelled the same I just was like
overwhelmed and the camera crew was
right there and I thought oh I don't
want to be on camera getting all misty
eyed so I went around and I sat in the
cockpit and looked up and there was Han
Solo's dice hanging there it's oh my
gosh
it's I still can't believe it's half it
happened and I was there
[Music]
Lucan r2d2 come back together after all
this time I was like oh my gosh I didn't
know how emotional that would feel to
watch yeah and you know everyone has
their contribution I think originally in
the script was bb-8 that came to the
island and ryan said no it should be r2
originally I didn't acknowledge Threepio
I walked right past him I said Ryan look
at after all those years of service even
though we hadn't been in contact in
recent years you know
Threepio was the closest to a sidekick I
had know Harrison had Julie and I had
our two or three vo but he's so
accommodating so collaborative he said
oh absolutely you should go over there
you should but he didn't really have
time to script anything he's just to
acknowledge him and that's what I did I
mean I don't remember actually doing
that and I did so that's the best kind
of spontaneity that you can have when
you don't say okay I'm gonna go in and
week out um I mean what happened
happened I thought what should I put in
my hand on the shoulders I shake hands
well I don't know because you know you
don't want to there's a solemnity to
that moment and you don't want to
trivialize it in any way but you know
that was special I mean obviously it
would be fun to have worked with with
Toni Daniel's a little bit more he was
since very amusing to say the least
[Music]